[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
crazy moves by a watercraft
captured on a sheriff's camera the
hardest thing about this case is solving
and the retrial of an iowa woman in the
death of her
own infant daughter
plus a kentucky state representative
arrested while protesting the police
killing of briana taylor
why she says she was targeted my
daughter and i and the people arrested
with us
have continued to show up for justice
for brianna taylor also
it seeks to acknowledge that there is in
fact racial bias
in our criminal justice system new
california laws aimed at making the
justice system
more just law on crime daily covers
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin authorities
say they've positively identified a
victim of one of the country's
most prolific serial killers terry
austin explains how investigators
cracked this cold case
terry erin for 40 years the family of
patricia parker had
no clue what happened to her but thanks
to tips from the community the georgia
bureau of investigation
now has an answer and it lies with dna
technology
parker's death is believed to be one of
93 murders committed by samuel little
the fbi says little is linked to
murdering women across
19 states for over a quarter of a
century
little has confessed to the murders and
drew portraits of his victims from
memory including a woman from
chattanooga tennessee
his description matched a 1981
unidentified remains case from dade
county georgia
gbi's cold case unit was called to
conduct a forensic analysis
we took the rendering had it sent to
north texas state to the dna lab out
there
dna was done we sent it off to the fbi
in quantico they did the dna test there
confirmed that it was ms parker after we
had been
we were reached out from the family to
let us know that they believed it was
hard we took dna samples from
the sun sent it off with the obama
and that's what the dna comparison came
up with miss parker was 30 years old
when she was killed she would be 69
years old
she's still alive today we made contact
with a family this morning to let them
know she has a son that's
still alive here in chattanooga to give
him
that closure and to kind of give him
some comfort that his mom didn't abandon
him
little is currently serving three life
sentences in california for strangling
women
kentucky state representative is
speaking out after some but not all of
the criminal charges against her were
dropped after she protested the police
killing of brianna taylor
attica scott is still facing misdemeanor
charges after protesting and then
entering church grounds for sanctuary
as a 9 pm curfew in her city kicked in
the church had agreed to be used as a
sanctuary for protesters
scott is also the author of a bill in
her state which aims to abolish
no knock warrants long crime's brian
buckmeyer spoke with the representative
and has her side of the story brian
representative scott tells me people
have been protesting the death of
brianna taylor in louisville
for more than 130 days she says that she
was arrested alongside
17 others protesting the grand jury's
indictment
of only one officer for wonton
endangerment
we were blocked in by a black
militarized vehicle
in a parking lot that also had another
entrance blocked off with the concrete
block so we couldn't get out
so we walked uh to the church just as we
were about to cross the street to the
church
police stopped us told us to turn around
then yelled
circle them circle them wouldn't let us
go anywhere
and proceeded to arrest us with their
guns in our faces their pepper ball guns
in our faces
and i was shocked i've never been
arrested before my teenage daughter was
with me so i was very concerned about
her safety
i was shocked that they would dare claim
that i would try to burn down the
library that's in my district district
41
the district that i serve that black
people desperately need so we fought
those uh absurd charges especially the
felony charge
and were very grateful when those
charges were dropped because quite
frankly brett hankinson the detective
who received a class d felony spent 32
minutes in jail
we received a class d felony and spent
10 hours in jail ridiculous
the state representative also says she
and her daughter were tear gassed
on day two of the protest she believes
she was targeted by the police because
of her bill to abolish no knock warrants
louisville passed brianna's law at the
local level we're expanding that they
ended no knock warrants locally
brianna's law for kentucky will end no
not warrant at the state level but it
would also mandate
that officers involved in deadly
shootings and other violent incidences
submit to alcohol and drug testing and
it would mandate that
any officer issuing a search warrant
must have on their body-worn camera
five minutes before and five minutes
after issuing uh that search warrant
of course they wanted to retaliate
against me for wanting to hold them
accountable
and i'm also suing them for tear-gassing
me and my child so of course they wanted
to retaliate against me
and i feel like that's what the county
attorney is doing right now by
only dropping the felony charges and now
making us wait until november 16th
to face the two misdemeanor charges
so brian this was a pretty amazing
interview just hearing from her
own sense her own perspective what
happened
if you were the criminal defense
attorney on this case how would you
handle it
oh i would just get ready for trial i
would be laughing at the prosecutors
saying
you created a system maybe not just you
but also attorney general cameron
created an environment where the entire
city is going to be behind
my client and if you think that a jury
of six people because now it's a
misdemeanor are going to find her guilty
after protesting the death of brianna
taylor and the way that this city
handled it
just bring discovery we'll start
whenever you want go right ahead put it
in front of a jury and you're going to
assume at least one person is going to
say forget it you know a quit
hung jury something like that so terry
how might a judge look at this case if
it winds up in front of a judge is there
even
cause to keep moving forward here well i
think the judge is going to look at it
the same way a jury would frankly and i
think the judge is going to say that
these protesters including the
representative
were getting into good trouble like the
rate late representative john lewis once
said
so chances are that these two
misdemeanor charges
are going to be dropped i think so
anyway so brian we're hearing from the
prosecutor's office that they dropped
the felony saying oh we didn't have
enough evidence explain that to us what
other evidence would they have needed to
go
forward with that yeah so they're
looking for writing they're going to
have to show or they would have have to
show up before
dropping that case or that charge sorry
that there was some sort of connection
between the representative and the 17
others were arrested who actually either
emboldened people to damage that
property or damage it themselves and of
course there's not that connection so
that's why that felony charge dropped
but they still have the unlawful
assembly
just because they were as they're
accusing him out past nine
a case to watch for sure brian thanks a
lot for speaking with the representative
for us
a nurse who spoke at the republican
national convention recently is in
trouble with the law
amy ford claimed self-defense after
shooting a woman
she was arguing with over the weekend
police chief in williamson west virginia
says ford shot victim yonder wit in the
abdomen wit had to be airlifted to the
hospital but is expected to survive
supreme court nominee amy coney barrett
is facing confirmation hearings in the
u.s capitol
barrett is president trump's nominee to
succeed justice ruth bader ginsburg who
died september 18th
the nominee has served as a federal
appeals court judge and as a professor
and
once was a law clerk for the late
justice antonin scalia
the proceedings are scheduled to take
four days key issues are expected to be
religion abortion access and health care
and still ahead here on law and crime
daily california lawmakers passed
sweeping reforms aimed at taking
race out of the criminal justice
equation and they could change the way
juries are picked and later on a mother
accused of strangling her daughter with
a pair of pajamas
it's a second trial was it murder or an
accident
[Music]
[Music]
a sheriff's department helicopter
catching dramatic video of a boat out of
control in florida the sheriff's
department says three people were on a
photo shoot
when they fell overboard and their boat
kept on going the people in the water
swam to safety one person had minor
injuries but the sheriff's department
had to fly over the scene to monitor the
situation
the boat eventually slamming into a
couple of docks and became slightly
airborne for a while
before ultimately coming to rest a
second trial is scheduled tomorrow for
an iowa mother accused of killing her
five-year-old daughter by strangling the
little girl with a pair of pajamas
a jury acquitted kelsey thomas of child
endangerment but was hung
on a murder charge she's chosen to be
tried by a judge
alone this time around firefighters
found victim chloe thomas dead in her
bedroom in july 2018.
thomas told detectives that she put
chloe down for a nap around 1 30 in the
afternoon and then took a nap herself
when she awoke she says she found her
daughter dead in a closet
and called 9-1-1 during the first trial
prosecutors said the defendant confessed
to murder and they argued no one else
could have killed the child
there's no evidence of struggle we know
the only people on that house
are the defendant chloe and her two
her two-year-old son when you look at
the scene photos
and the evidence or the testimony that
came to you from the officers and the
first responding officers
you heard that there's no vomit in that
closet
because counselor because chloe was
never in that closet
that was the defendant's story when she
was trying to come up with something
the pants and the vomit are both on the
bed
that's consistent with what the
defendant tells you it corroborates her
story
those pants aren't in the closet even if
you believe
her first second third version about
what happened to those pants
why would she pick up those pants and
put them on the bed this is somebody if
you believe her story
that is walks into this room and sees
her daughter hanging there
even if you believe the pants fell off
why would you then pick up the pants and
bring them on the bed
because that never happened the parents
were on the bed
because she dropped them after she
strangled her just like she told you
through her confession
the defense said the confession was
coerced and insisted the evidence proves
it they asked the jury to find their
client not
shannon was guilty painting in her
closet just as kelsey said
everything that she did that day
everything that she
experienced that day is consistent with
that
for all the ways in which the state
tries to trip her up and yes she
ultimately confesses
in every way the state tells her to
confess
and i've documented that for you
sometimes
innocent people confess to crimes they
didn't commit
this isn't a false confession case
because i got an expert to say that it
is
like i said dr keller merely opened your
eyes
to what i just showed you
you've got a medical examiner who was
not confident in her opinion
even before you heard from dr young i
can't imagine that you had a lot of
confidence in her opinion in the first
place
if ever there was a false confession
case
i could not imagine how it would be
supported more
than in a case like this
okay so let's jump in for some analysis
right now terry what's your assessment
of the defendant's
choice to be tried by a judge rather
than a jury here
the jury was hung the last time and as
criminal defense attorneys like brian
buckmeyer might often say
all you need is that one juror to shut
down the state's case
if they tried this in front of a jury
they could have another hung jury the
state may have to give up
so why go with the judge i couldn't
agree with you more aaron i mean most
criminal defendants they're going to
take advantage of the sixth amendment
right to a jury of your peers
and here for whatever reason she's
deciding to put her fate before the
judge
and we know judges are going to apply
the law and they're going to be
objective so
i think it's the wrong choice
particularly since she did fairly well
in front of the jury before yeah brian
how would
would you advise this client you know
would you say this is a good idea to go
with a bench trial this time around
i mean me personally no i i for example
trust a juror of peers more than i would
a single judge i actually put in an
order it's
jury judge bears and then prosecutors in
terms of who i trust more
uh and i wouldn't do this but if i get a
wink and a nod from a judge instead of
technical argument
which i think it might be then maybe
just maybe
you go with a bench trial yeah there may
be some uh you know one of those little
wink and nods here where
maybe the defense thinks that the judge
might be a little bit favorable to a
technical legal argument here i agree
that that might happen
so brian how would you defend kelsey
thomas factually would you turn around
and say the confession was coerced she
didn't do it
this wouldn't be a factual argument
again because it's a judge trial i'm
going to stick to the burden of proof
and i'm going to hold tight to that
burden and say these
facts don't really add up to what the
prosecutor is looking to do
and the best example of that is the
previous trial where they acquitted on
the lower charge of endangering a child
leading up to a death and were hung on
the murder charge
that tells me something's fishy here
we'll watch the trial when it kicks off
tomorrow and still to come here on law
and crime daily a series of bills usher
in sweeping criminal justice reform
measures for the state of california
we break down the changes with one of
the advocates who helped make them
happen
[Music]
a criminal justice group called the
reform alliance involves big names like
meek mill
jay-z and even new england patriots
owner robert kraft
and it's taking some credit for a series
of bills recently signed into law in
california
one of the five bills says plainly that
it seeks to eliminate
racial bias from california's criminal
justice
system the policy director of the reform
alliance spoke with me recently and said
the legislation was oftentimes based on
actual cases
where shocking problems were uncovered
the most powerful examples are always
real life examples
as people who work in policy we can
always point to
statistics we can make things abstract
but there is nothing like real life
examples
especially told by people who lived
through those real life examples so at
reform alliance as well as at
several other policy organizations i
think what we found is that really these
criminal justice reforms need to be led
by people who are themselves directly
impacted
who have lived through this injustice
who know what
who know what it really means to
experience that type of injustice
and who in fact are the best messengers
to say to the lawmakers
this is the problem this is how it
manifests and
this is the change that we need to
correct it the
people involved in this reform you're
working some very famous people on these
bills and some famous voices have been
behind them how important are those
voices
in the conversation i think everybody's
voice is honestly incredibly important
we talked a little bit earlier about the
importance of having people with direct
experiences really lead this movement
for decades now we've had a lot of
publicity around the negative stories
around criminal justice reform and sort
of law and order
we have you know 50 different types of
csi shows
and so we've had many many people who
have really used their platform
to help advance kind of fear-mongering
and and stricter tougher law and order
and so i think one of the things that
we're seeing right now um is a counter
narrative to that so we have
incredible influencers um and incredible
advocates people like kim kardashian
who doesn't just talk the talk but
really walks the walk and studies all of
this
we have incredible advocates like john
legend like reform alliance's board
members meek mill
jay-z um you know we we just have put
together i think a really incredible
coalition and their voices have been so
so important just as people with direct
experience have been
so important in leading this fight and
when we come back a look at what some of
the reformers uncovered when pushing for
change
and will explain changes to the
probation system which will
alter the way incarceration rates stack
up in the golden states
[Music]
new laws in california are aimed to
repair what advocates say
is a deeply broken criminal justice
system some of the troubling cases
reformers uncovered included a
conviction based in part on what the
legislation calls an expert's
racist testimony that people of indian
descent
are predisposed to commit bribery
another example is that defendants have
no recourses if their own attorney
harbors racial animus
towards the defendant's racial group and
the new laws aim to change existing
court precedents
that say appellate courts must defer to
the rulings of judges
who make racially biased comments during
jury selection
all of these things happen in real cases
cited by the new laws
reform alliance policy director erin
haney says one of the new laws
changes the way defendants serve their
sentences
what we found is that there are so many
studies that show
that the best amount of time to be under
supervision in any state
for any offense is actually 18 months or
less
probation is most effective within that
period of time
and when you keep people on probation
for longer than that
what ends up happening is that you see
people going back
into prison for technical violations
which are non-crimes um so this could be
being late to a meeting with your
probation officer
not being able to keep full-time
employment any number of conditions of
probation
so by changing something like the amount
of time that you are sentenced to
probation in california
just from three years to one year for
misdemeanors and from
five years down to two years for
felonies you
actually save over five years 48
000 plus prison admissions just for
technical violations
and 24 000 years of freedom so there
will be people
who would have been locked inside a
prison on technical violations because
they have been sentenced to
three years or five years who will now
be free
and be able to be productive members of
their communities
how hard was it to convince the governor
and the legislature to pass these
reforms
assembly assemblymember comlogger was
just a force of nature
as was assembly member ash kara buffy
wicks
there were just so many people who
worked incredibly incredibly hard to get
these reforms passed governor gavin
newsom has been such a great leader
in criminal justice in the state of
california and so
we owe so much to him he is managing so
many different things and for him to
step
up and be this leader on criminal
justice reform
especially when we need it the most was
really really
incredible and really i think gave a lot
of advocates so much hope this year
so terry one of the other new laws
changes the way attorneys can strike
members of a jury pool it's illegal in
california now as a matter of state
statute to use race to strike a member
of the jury pool it's been part of
federal case law for a while but
my understanding is is this codifies it
in california
and it changes some of the precise
parameters of the procedure
yeah i mean governor newsome has been
doing a lot this is assembly bill
3070 and what it would do is limit the
removal of prospective jurors
without cause so that actually prevents
discrimination based on race and other
backgrounds
so it would also shift the burden of
proof to the attorney who rejected the
juror
and that attorney would have to provide
a reason for the exclusion so you just
can't
exclude people for any nilly willy basis
brian do you think the new procedures
outlined in california would really help
public defenders such as yourself
i want to say yes aaron because i
applaud these people for
what they've put out there but the
reality is no i think that this is only
half of the picture i think this is
persuasive arguments that you can
present to a judge but unless there are
teeth on the back end of that
to make this binding upon judges or
those who are going to implement these
harsh punishments
on my clients and others this isn't
going to go far enough
these laws are pages and pages long we
certainly can continue to dig into them
thank you very much for joining us here
on law and crime daily appreciate it
very much we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions we break down the
case of a serial killer another day of
drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law and crime
[Music]
you